I'm a great fan of dairy products for
humans in general but dairy is a very
complex food socially and and
nutritionally and culturally and so it
requires a little bit that statement
requires a little bit of unpacking many
many cultures thrive on dairy products
of all kinds the the best dairy products
are our traditional so they come from
grass-fed cows the milk is on
homogenized the milk is ideally
unpasteurized or raw because there are
many heat sensitive nutrients in milk
and and then those dairy products are
often prepared in traditional ways so
usually fermented or cultured made into
cheese or yogurt or butter which is
really just removing everything but the
fat g which is truly everything but the
fat so we start there the the best area
is traditional and it's often prepared
in a way that makes it more digestible
for people who are not accustomed to
consuming fresh dairy products in
adulthood so it has been suggested that
many people are lactose intolerant this
isn't really accurate what what we're
actually describing is in adulthood we
stop producing lactase the enzyme which
helps us break down fresh milk we're all
born producing lots and lots of lactase
because we are mammals and and we're
breastfed traditionally so in a few
cultures the adults carry on producing
this enzyme which allows them to digest
fresh milk but particularly if they
lived in hog cultures they weren't able
to keep fresh milk from spoiling hence
the the production of yogurt and other
things to keep fresh milk around for
more than a day or two so if you have a
look you can find actually the the
ability to continue to produce lactase
in adulthood has arisen as as a as a as
a genetic capacity as a competence of
the human body in multiple places in
human history so lots of people can
produce the lactase to digest freshman
and a number of those genetic mutations
for that's what they are have occurred
in Africa as well so the idea that I'm
Asian or I'm African African or Asian
origin and I can't digest milk is simply
untrue that said there are cultures who
thrive without dairy products altogether
there are some in Asia and it is quite
possible to feed a human beautifully
without consuming any dairy products so
the question is where to get the
nutrients dairy products contain in the
in the historic traditional fairly
recent American diet dairy products are
just flat out one of the best sources of
fat soluble vitamins A and D and of
calcium they're a beautiful beautiful
beautiful balanced recipe for protein
fat and carbohydrates which is one of
the reasons I love milk for four
children and and pregnant women and
nursing mothers and you can if you need
to get get these nutrients somewhere
else so the the place to get them if you
don't thrive on our care for dairy
products is bone broth for the calcium
and other minerals so chicken soup beef
broth veal stock and the vitamins A and
D you'll get from seafood and pork
products egg yolks to
well the first thing to understand about
the FDA is that the USDA and FDA and and
other government institutions are very
critical of traditional foods without
actually applying objective standards to
how those traditional foods might be
prepared in a safe and healthy and
hygienic manner and so all their numbers
on raw milk are dubious there are a
number of foodborne contaminants and
illnesses which are posed a much much
greater risk to you and me statistically
than the consumption of raw milk that
said if you choose to consume
traditional foods such as raw fish which
I eat or raw milk which I drink and my
whole family drinks including our
children you need to be absolutely sure
of the source and find someone who cares
a great deal about traditional methods
of production and hygiene so why do we
drink rim raw milk even though there is
a small chance we'll get sick well I I
find first after doing all my research
that I trust the traditional food chain
more than I trust the industrial food
chain there there a number of risks were
meeting industrial food and I try to
minimize and avoid those risks too we
drink raw milk simply because it's got
more good food in it so there are a
couple of heat sensitive nutrients in
raw milk which are of interest one is he
tensed vitamins some of the B vitamins
are damaged by pasteurization another is
that the fats are rather delicate in
milk the omega-3 fats are sensitive to
heat and there will be Omega 3 fats in
grass fed milk and so it's nice to
preserve those another is enzymes which
help you digest the other nutrients in
milk so here are some enzymes which are
deactivated or a deactivator or
otherwise somehow limited after
pasteurization lipase which helps you
digest lipids or fats phosphatase which
helps you absorb calcium a key nutrient
and milk which is why raw milk contains
more available calcium
and our old friend lactase the enzyme
that helps you digest lactose the basic
carbohydrate in milk and there are tons
of milk sugars but lactose is the big
one is is damaged by pasteurization so I
have met not a few people who say they
were doubled over from from from gut
pain when they drank milk and concluded
they were so-called lactose intolerant
who drank fresh clean raw milk without
any trouble well it contains plenty of
lactase
there's a lot to understand about real
legs and industrial legs and there is a
vast difference between them that said I
want my bumper sticker to be that eggs
are real food and everyone should eat
real food because they are also a great
food a whole fresh egg that is the yolk
the white inside the shell they're a
great frugal real food so if you're
anywhere near the poverty line eat eggs
anyway wherever you can find them just
don't eat some kind of fake egg or
re-engineered and reassembled egg so now
what is the best egg an industrial egg
comes from a chicken she's in a little
cage with some other chickens there are
I have been on chicken farms where the
farmer was boasting that he put only
three hens in a cage which actually
permits nine the chickens were still on
top of each other she never goes
outdoors artificial light tells her
little ovaries when to lay an egg and
she is fed she spent chicken feed that
may contain other animal parts it may
contain o plate waste or parts of pigs
or cattle or other chicken and that's
because the chicken is an omnivore she
can't live on grass and plants alone she
needs some protein she needs some bugs
she needs some corn and other grain and
her eggs are in addition to causing
suffering to the lame hen herself her
eggs lack the rich vitamin A that she
would get from eating the beta-carotene
and grass and they lack the omega-3 fats
which she would get from eating worms
and bugs if she were actually running
around so then we have organic eggs
which are you typically fed vegetarian
feed that's a good thing because they're
they're not eating other ground up
animals it's a bad thing because
chickens really do want to be outside
and if they'd been outside a little they
would have eaten a worm they wouldn't be
strictly vegetarian the you might find a
free-range on the label with or without
the term organic Oh she'll be eating
organic fee
so there no pesticides in intervene
which is a good thing if you see the
term free range this merely means that
she is not caged and there is a wide
range of of actual practices which
attach to the label free range so free
range is better but not necessarily
great doesn't mean necessarily that she
goes outside and so the the happiest ten
with the healthiest eggs for you it's a
so-called pastured him and it means that
she goes outside and in the dead of the
winter they can send them outside to
this this not a lot to eat out there in
say upstate New York which is my region
in the dead of winter I know farmers who
throw alfalfa sprouts and other things
over the side so their chickens are
getting some greenery scratching in the
dirt is what chickens love most of all
and they'll do it even in the snow so
look for the term pastured if you can